(heavy drumming)
Please welcome Drew Barrymore.
(crowd clapping)
Thank you guys, so much.
Welcome, welcome, welcome to the show.
I would love to spend the next hour having a blast,
figuring out the good stuff in life,
having many different kinds of conversation.
And I really like getting some good news
because it's just nice to know,
and sometimes you really need it.
So, let's hit the headlines.
(upbeat music)
(crowd cheering)
It's time for Drew's News,
your ring-a-ding-ding on the good news telly.
And with me at the desk is a fine chap indeed, Ross Mathews.
Hello. Hi.
Hey everybody. Hi.
All right. Well, let's jump into the news.
We all know that pandemic pets were a huge phenomenon,
but there's so many cuties who still need homes.
Shelters and rescue, they use every tool in the box
to get pets adopted,
including insanely cute names.
The Washington Post reports an adorable name
can really get a pet noticed.
That's right, there's even a Twitter account
Petfinder Names, that highlight the cream of the crop.
Let's check out Ed Sheeran.
Oh yeah.
That's cute.
I mean this works.
Yeah.
Look at Adam Sandler, the gecko.
Who doesn't want a Sandler?
Oh.
Right?
Yeah. I would love if they get creative
and do like Brad Pitbull,
Katty Perry.
Yeah, exactly.
And the good news is as much as, you know,
rescues always needs support,
the pandemic did have some positive news
that so many pets did get adopted.
They did. And this is great.
I know, gimme the good news.
I actually, I have a little surprise for you.
I love surprises.
I know you do.
Well, you're gonna love this.
It's a duo from Ruff Start Rescue in Princeton, Minnesota.
They're special because these two little kittens,
these are brothers and sisters.
They're what they call a bonded pair,
which means they have to be adopted together
because they love each other so much.
And do you know what they have named
these two little kittens Drew?
This brother and sister?
Meet Drew Barrymore and Ross Mathews.
No.
Yes, they legit named them after us.
And they tell us that Ross is a little nervous nellie
(Ross laughing)
and Drew is braver and calmer than Ross.
Wait, this is real?
Yeah, they named them after us two
and they're up for adoption.
Which one's which?
Okay, let's take a look.
Can we bring them back up?
There's Drew.
(Drew gasps)
And the kitty is Ross?
Ross. There's Ross.
You can tell 'cause the little gray.
(audience laughing)
Oh my gosh.
We're going to have to do something about that.
Now are you going to get more pets?
Well, my daughter does want another cat.
We already have two.
This is why Dr. Drewlittle was actually born
because our family has six chickens,
two cats, two dogs, one fish,
and our bearded dragon named Jeremy.
I swear, I think I'm forgetting some.
We did have guinea pigs,
but we found homes for them
because I was like, I can't take this anymore.
I've become, literally, the insane person
with the menagerie.
I was like, we gotta find these guinea pigs homes.
Daisy, who was such a grump too,
but we found her a loving home.
What is a grumpy guinea pig like?
Well, I don't think any of them were that enthusiastic.
(Ross laughing)
They're sort of introverts.
Yes. But I was like, we got to find a home
that's like, not so busy and can focus on Daisy.
So we found a home for Daisy.
Good. Thrilled for Daisy.
Yeah, I think we should check into the cat situation.
Which one of your daughters wants another cat?
Olive.
Yes, some of it's for her. Some of it's for me.
I end up taking care of them.
We're going to check in with those animals afterwards.
Okay. All right. How cute though?
I know you'd love that.
Yeah.
Well, our next story comes
from some pet owners in Chicago.
When Nicole Sopko and Dan Staackmann's beloved dog,
Greta, passed away last spring.
We all know how hard that can be.
It was a few months before they found Frida,
an eight year old from Texas who needed a home.
And people reports the couple ran a doggy DNA test on her,
and get this,
they found out that Frida and Greta
were shockingly cousins.
What?
Yes, Nicole and Dan say it confirmed
what they already knew in their hearts,
that Frida was meant to be a part of their family.
Why is this not an animated movie?
Drew Barrymore, don't you have power?
Come on, let's make this happen.
I'll call Netflix.
Do you know what's so funny?
A part of me is listening to this story and I'm so happy.
Like, this is definitely should be a movie,
but I'm like, oh, there is no way I'm getting DNA tests
for all the animals at my house.
I'll be running a lab.
And I'm like, guess what?
You came from Jersey.
You, I don't know.
North Valley, Hollywood, you know.
Like wherever you came from, you came from.
Moving on.
Well, I did do DNA tests on my three rescue dogs.
Of course you did.
Of course I did because, hello. But there they are.
Yeah. That's Selena, Audrey, and Pa Earl,
named after my great grandpa, Pa Earl.
And you know what the DNA test told me?
That they're chihuahuas.
(Drew laughing)
Thanks so much for that science.
Maybe I didn't pay for the upgrade
where you can find out if they're cousins,
but I just picture us like on Maury Povich
and him being like, you are not the breeder.
I'll show Douglas and Lucy.
They're from California
and I'm like, wherever they're from...
Fillmore. Lucy came from Fillmore,
Douglas from North Hollywood.
North Hollywood.
Yeah.
Okay. That's a cool area.
Okay. Well, that's interesting, pet DNA.
Well maybe when you rescue
Ross Mathews and Drew Barrymore,
we can test their DNA.
Maybe.
(upbeat music)